let's see okay why don't we go to our
caller from the two four eight area code
who's calling today from two four eight
that me yeah that's you who's this
this is Joseph from Michigan
hey Joseph what's going on I just wanted
to to give a big thank you uh because
you you and Kyle kolinsky really helped
pull me out of a really a really far
right place that had been over the past
few years how'd you get into that far
right so so uh but my family was pretty
liberal so I was just you know kind of
like another caller it called not too
long ago yeah I just kind of you know
that when I started getting to politics
I just automatically assumed oh hey I
just you know gonna be on the left but
uh what happened was I came across a
video from a youtuber known as shoe on
head mm-hm and there was like oh you
know just person on the left criticizing
people on the left but then from her I
got two armored skeptic her her her
boyfriend now fiance I think and from
him I got to Blair white and just kept
going down this rabbit hole until
eventually I was watching uh until
eventually watching stefan molyneux in
lauren southern and of and eventually uh
i lost to eventually i watch a video by
TJ kirk where he references kyle
kolinsky so i went to watch him and in
the recommended of the video wasn't from
him i got a video from you and I was
lost in you too for like the past six
months and you've really a deprogram me
pulled me out of the place that was that
well listen I appreciate that I also am
a little concerned about one element of
this and this is a broader issue that
goes beyond not not to pick on you but
let me ask you this how long would you
say the process was from where you sort
of got politically aware on the left was
pulled into the right and then back to
the left like how long did that entire
process take maybe four years okay all
right that's
concerning I you know sometimes when
folks call in Joseph and they say a very
similar story to the one you told but
they say it happened within like a year
or ten months that's concerning to me
because I'm worried that people are so
malleable that they can so quickly be
pulled in to such extreme ideology and
then just by virtue of other videos that
they watch on YouTube be pulled directly
out of it like in an ideal world it's so
great that you were pulled out of that
right and it's it's absolutely fantastic
that they happened and I'm really glad
in an ideal world we would be teaching
critical thinking and philosophy and
civics starting at an early enough age
where one could not by virtue of
stumbling across some whack-jobs on
YouTube be pulled into these outrageous
beliefs to begin with you know what I
mean oh yeah it was a very slow process
yeah I guess it was like first on the
left criticizing people on the left it
was like okay maybe Center ism is cool
and then slowly okay maybe this right
ringer has a point okay maybe they have
two points it it is slowly devolved from
there what would you say was the most
extreme belief that you actually sort of
incorporated into your set of beliefs
the belief to ban all immigration coming
into the u.s. that's interesting I know
a bunch of people that have called in
and said that they were pulled into the
right and then got out of it
a lot of them say that they were pulled
into the right with immigration related
you know it's sort of pseudo nationalist
xenophobic anti-immigrant stuff that
that is interesting I mean it's
anecdotal it's just people who call me
but that is notable that a bunch of them
mention that oh yeah it's a big it's a
big thing getting cold it is it is the
immigration thing yeah Joseph listen I'm
glad you got out and appreciate you
telling me your story thank you
okay protect my call take care of
appreciated Joseph seem to have a
strange kind of like delay going on with
Joseph it was weird I don't know if
that's in the system or that was just
the call with a call Joseph